avec son crépi immaculé l'église de
sennecey lès dijon est clair le paysage
bâtie sur des fondations du 11e siècle
elle a retrouvé une seconde jeunesse
depuis deux ans grâce aux travaux
réalisés à l'initiative de la mairie et
de l'association des amis de saint
maurice mais à l'intérieur
électricité menuiserie chauffage tout
est à refaire
on est à peu près à 400000 euros de
travaux donc même si on divise en 3 ça
fait quand même des tranches qui sont
importantes
c'est une somme importante puisqu'en
fait qu a pas eu de campagne de travaux
dans l'église depuis 1981
la mairie propriétaire du bâtiment ne
peut pas financer seuls quatre cent
mille euros de travaux entre 2020 et
d'autant que l'église n'est pas classée
comme c'est souvent le cas dans les
petites communes
il va falloir chercher des subventions
on est dans l'assemblage de petites
sommes deviennent grosse à la fin mais
on va les rechercher le moindre
partenariats possibles auprès de l'état
du département auprès des associations
des entreprises depuis 2014
neuf mille euros ont été collectés en
partenariat avec la fondation du
patrimoine
ces dons ont co financé la restauration
de cinq statues classé des 15e et 17e
siècles ainsi que cette vierge à
l'enfant pour les amis de saint maurice
l'église retrouve peu à peu des couleurs
ç'a permis d'intéresser les habitants à
ses statuts parce que pour certains
peut-être perdu un peu l'habitude de les
voir aujourd'hui ça ne ça nous dit qu'il
faut vraiment faire l'intérieur d'église
parce que des statues sont belles
malheureusement
l'écrin c'est un peu bizarre et voilà
l'histoire ne dit pas si saint maurice
un légionnaire mort en suisse au 3e
siècle est passé par la voie romaine qui
traversait alors cnc